- Good morning Believe
Nation, today's message is
take your shot!
Over to you Henry Rollins.
(rooster crowing)
♫ I wake up every morning,
espresso keep me going.
♫ I wake up every morning.
- The last straight job I had was 1981.
Head manager of a Haagen
Dazs in Georgetown,
the Washington DC on Wisconsin
Avenue at the intersection
of Wisconsin and O Street
making $3.75 an hour
or $4 an hour something like that.
Working 40 to 60 hours a week.
I had a small apartment which I shared
with an old pal of mine.
I had a small record collection,
an ailing V.W. automobile,
and a little tiny life with my
minimum wage job which I liked.
And I looked at my life and
realized this is probably
about as good as it's going to get for me.
I might quit this place
and go work at my friend's
record store, cause I
liked being around records
that I could probably
run his store very well,
knowing what I knew about
retail at that point.
And then I got a very lucky break.
Cause at that same time
I was very frustrated.
I'd say well, this is going
to be a very tough life.
It's going to be a life of a
lot of standing on my feet,
a lot of work, taking
it from other people,
and having very little to
show for it by Friday evening.
Then Black Flag, the famous
band who is friends of mine,
they played in New York.
I was in Washington.
I took a ride up to go see them cause
they weren't coming down to my town.
I jumped on stage and sang
with them that night a song.
Cause I had to go back down to DC
and go work some awful shift.
They called me a few days
later at the ice cream store
and said we're looking for
a singer cause the rhythm
guitar player wants to, I'm
sorry the vocalist wants to
move down to rhythm guitar.
You can tell I've told this story before.
And we're holding auditions,
do you want a crack at this?
Cause we saw you on stage the other night,
you're pretty wild.
I looked at the ice cream scoop in my hand
my chocolate spattered apron,
and my future in the world
of minimum wage work, or
I could go up to New York
and audition for this crazy
band who is my favorite.
What's the worse that's
going to happen to me?
I miss a day of work.
Ooh, there goes 21 bucks.
And I get humiliated in
front of my favorite band.
Humiliation and young
people kind of go together.
I was use to it.
So I took a train up there,
I walked into this practice
place in the East Village.
I'm standing there with the band
with a microphone in my hand.
They said pick the tune.
I sang every song they had,
improvising most of it,
two times through, we did the set.
They said okay, you have a seat.
We're going to go have a band
meeting. Whatever that means.
And they came back like ten minutes later
and they said okay, you're in.
I said what do you mean? They said
you're the singer in Black Flag.
I said so what do I do?
They go, you quit your
job, you pack your gear,
you meet us on the road.
Here's the tour itinerary,
here's the lyrics. We'll see you soon.
So fairly numb, I went back
down to Washington with
this passel of lyrics in my hand.
Went to my boss and said
I'm not exactly quitting,
but here's this thing that happened.
He said, it's your shot, I said yeah.
He said, take it.
- When I was 20 years old,
I missed my shot because
I was scared and I vowed
never to do it again.
I was in Paris, I was on
vacation, I was in University.
I'm sitting here with my map,
outside the Notre Dame Cathedral in Paris.
And a girl comes up and
asks me for directions.
But she was a French girl.
And it didn't twig until later, that
why would a French girl be
asking me for directions
in English, didn't
really make sense right?
And then I thought, you know
what I should ask her out.
Just see what she's doing
tonight, should take her to,
ask her out for coffee
or dinner or something.
See what she's up to.
But I was afraid. I was afraid to do it.
I let her walk away, because really
I was afraid of rejection.
As she's walking away, the
Notre Dame is on a river,
and I'm on one side of the
river, and she crosses over
to the other side of the river.
I was so upset at myself
that I didn't' take my shot.
I was so upset that I didn't try.
At least try.
What I did was I ended
up taking a picture.
As I took the picture,
she actually walked behind
one of the market stalls,
and I didn't actually get her
picture, it's fine. So I
have this beautiful picture
of this French riverside.
What I did when I got home,
I was still upset about it.
I blew the picture up,
and I put it on my wall.
I was actually trying to find
the picture to show you guys.
But I couldn't find it
anywhere in my files.
I blew it up though and
I put it on my wall,
so I'm at University,
everybody who walks in asks me
about the picture, and
it just looks like a nice
beautiful French scene.
But I didn't' tell anybody what
it really represented to me.
Why it was really so important.
And I looked at that picture
everyday, because the next time
that I had to take my shot I
wanted to go out and do it.
I didn't want to be afraid,
I wanted to conquer my fear
and say yes. And this
served me really well
A year or so later when I
had to make the really tough
decision, do I take this
job that I always wanted.
That had these high
paying job opportunities
80-100 thousand dollar
starting salary with a company
that I really wanted to go at.
Or continue with my start
up that was failing,
that was making $300 a month.
The logical, practical,
safe, easy thing to do
would have been to take the job.
It's what I thought I always wanted,
it's what my friends wanted,
it's what you're suppose to do
coming out of University.
I didn't want to live with
the regret of not knowing
what happened with my business.
Looking at that picture
daily reminded me to take
my shot the next time it comes around.
I gave myself a year to say, I'm
going to push off those jobs.
They'll still be there in a year.
Even if it's not those
jobs, it's some other job.
I'm going to give this a shot.
I can deal with the failure.
I can deal with the rejection.
I can deal with it not working
out, even though that's
really kind of short term intense pain.
What I can't deal with is
the regret of not knowing
because that's not some short term
minimal pain, that's forever.
If I chose not to focus on my
business, and I took that job.
I would forever look back
on that moment and think
what if? What if I just
tried a little bit harder?
What if I gave it a little bit more?
Yeah you know but it wasn't working,
it wasn't getting results.
But what if I gave it a little bit more?
I did not want to live with that regret.
I'm sure you've had
moments in your life too,
where you didn't take the shot.
Where you had an opportunity
right in front of you
and you didn't go for it.
Like Eminem says, if you had
one shot, one opportunity
to seize everything you ever
wanted, would you take it?
That picture on the wall
helped me take my shot.
I hope sincerely that the
next time you get your chance
at something, that you don't shrink down,
that you don't say no out of fear.
That you don't say no
because you find some
practical reason why you can't do it.
That you take your shot, and if you've
had those moments that you regret,
where you wanted to take
your shot and you didn't.
Give yourself a visual
reminder like I did in my room.
To say this is not happening again.
Next time, I'm going to take my shot.
I hope you take yours.
So the question of the
day today is I'm curious;
What is a shot you didn't take?
What's your biggest regret in life or
business for you right now?
Write it down, make it painful,
go back into that terrible memory.
Cause I never want that
to happen to you again.
So write it down, leave
it in the comments.
I'm looking forward to seeing
what you guys put down.
Finally I want to give a quick
shout out to Ingrid Prescott.
Ingrid thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book.
"Your One Word," I really
appreciate your support.
Thank you guys so much for watching.
I believe in you, I hope
you continue to believe
in yourself, and whatever
your one word is,
and I'll see you again
tomorrow morning for another
shot of espresso.
♫ I wake up every morning,
espresso keep me going.
Hey Believe Nation, thank
you so much for watching.
If you want to learn
more about this subject,
get a little bit deeper on it,
I'm going to share some extra bonus clips
that I hope you'll enjoy.
- After you moved to LA from Hawaii,
you got there and what's the reason
to leave Hawaii in the first place?
- I think I needed to take a shot
at the big time.
I wanted to make my album,
and start writing my own music,
I've been performing my
whole life in Hawaii,
in Waikiki and parties,
wedding, and shows.
Anything you could think of.
Restaurants, bars, and clubs.
I feel like I did a lot
in Hawaii and I wanted to,
as soon as I graduated
high school, I wanted to
take the next step and
hopefully do it even bigger.
- You got there to LA with just
your suitcase probably?
- Wasn't even my suitcase.
- Any money?
- Absolutely not.
I probably had about
600 bucks I'd saved up.
700 maybe.
- What was the plan then?
How did you feel at this
special moment getting there and having
no clue what's going to happen next?
- It was exciting, I was
young, my sister helped me out.
She let me stay with her for a year
and I got signed to Motown records.
That didn't really work
out, but I had to learn.
It's such a learning process
and a lot of rejection.
I think people have to
understand that it's just a part
of what it takes to finally
come up with your own album.
You need to be rejected over and over.
And everyone telling you
you're not good enough,
to kind of break though
that, that's what it takes.
- You sent unfinished
work to Stephen Sondheim
for him to critique.
- Well it was pretty well
(mumbles) by the time I sent it.
- So Steve, just tell me what you think.
How does that work, and are you really ...
- Yeah, it's ...
It's a crazy idea. But in my
head it was a really good idea.
Sometimes what you need are people
to just not say that's a terrible idea.
You have to be very careful
about who you let in
when you've had a good
idea, because people
can crush it for you.
People can go no, I would
stick to this other thing.
If you trust that person,
and you love that person,
it can really affect your
own view of your work.
I learned that the hard way,
I've had ideas die in front of me.
Because people I respect go,
maybe not that one so much.
When I was on vacation and I picked up
Chirinos' book and I started reading it
and reading it to my wife and being like,
there's something here.
Being like I'm not a crazy person.
My wife was like no
that's a really cool idea.
That's as responsible for this as anything
I remember when I first met Sondheim,
it was to do translations for the
last revival of West Side Story.
We talked shop, and we talked
about what should translate,
and what I shouldn't, and
we kind of talked about
that for about a half an hour.
Then he asked me about what
are you thinking about next.
Heights was running at the
time, it was it's first year.
I said, I think I have this
idea, Alexander Hamilton.
He threw up his head and
made this, and he's a really
reserved guy, and he went that
is the most incredible idea.
I just instantly got up and I was like ...
That's also as responsible
for us being here as anything.
That early encouragement, his whole thing.
He's proved it with his career.
Continue to bury and like
lean into what scares you
and lean into what people don't think
makes a good musical and make that.